Eric Tammy acacia here Mary you're on
the couch oh my god it's great what's
going on back there josh is on his own
no Danny with him nothing's on fire
don't worry about it dime ahora putting
out fires we can have you here for like
5-10 minutes and because Dark Souls 3
and 2 you got to play it this week or
have them playing it since monday and i
know you're kind of in the same boat as
me because you're a blood you've played
blood-borne not a big souls fan correct
that's the same for me but Mary you're a
fan of the series and you've been
playing them all just the Dark Souls 1
sorry I didn't play demon's souls but
yeah so I guess the question is what is
your initial impression of Dark Souls 3
what's new first of all night yeah
there's a lot of new stuff that they're
adding to try to revamp it first of all
your way faster they've increased your
stamina and stamina regens faster so I
think they're taking a little bit from
blood-borne and they're trying to get
you to move around and dodge a little
bit more although it is still very
focused on using a shield and then
attacking although that's not days wit a
likes to dodge but you'll find in a lot
of these fights I can easily run away
and I can kind of Dodge I can run past
enemies really quickly which you weren't
able to do in previous games but I think
they're encouraging it more they want
you to be moving around a little bit
more so the stress test was on was it
just Monday surprise last week was yeah
it was friday to sunday at specific time
periods we had about three hours each
day yep to try it out there were four
new classes well I mean like there's
four classes that are playable I think
there was only two before this stress
test so the two new ones is the Academy
assassin and The Herald of white and The
Herald of white and they both have magic
The Herald of white is kind of more of
like one calm like a cleric paladin but
he has the ability to bluff himself his
attack and his defense as one of his
spells and then the other one allows him
to heal and then he also has lightning
strike and then the Academy assassin is
very magic based they have three magic
moves there's there's a dagger which is
really quick there's a longer move
a little bit more damage and this is
giant circular sword move which is
really rad so another new thing is
there's a mana bar and they're letting
you regen your mana at at bonfires and
then they also have an ash Estus flask
which is similar to your regular Estus
flask it just regens your mana and
because of that Estus flask you can just
burn through your mana you can just go
go go and pretty much do magic tricks
all day which I thought they always
tried to not let you do a lot of ranged
attacks and Dark Souls they want you to
be up close they like that close combat
but with but with the Magic Man you can
just rain down Hogwarts on these run
train on pretty much everyone from a
long distance I found it a little opie
but the problem with judging this is
that it's a stress test this isn't a
demo this isn't a preview build a lot of
this stuff isn't final yet ask them yeah
but it song it's a march so presumably
alright there's still some stuff that
they're they're working on here I asked
them about the the cap on your your
health as in previous games when you die
you lose your max health and it goes
down and down and down until you until
you get your humanity back yeah and in
this one in this demo that doesn't
happen and I asked them about that and
they said they hadn't decided yet Wow
okay so there's no way to know how your
health is actually and that's a huge
change right so there's some so does it
feel like there are big changes cuz then
the other problem I was filled with
these games is that whenever I like I'm
not a massive fan so I can't speak to
her personally but listening to
conversations in the office it always
feels like the real changes in these
games like aren't really apparent until
like a week or two weeks afterward some
people are like diving into it and like
figuring out how each game plays
differently so when just did it feel
like a different sort of Dark Souls
experience like when you compare it to
something with 22 specifically I would
say that it's in the same realm they've
made minor tweaks there's a little bit
more speed there's um arts now there's
weapon arts where you can change your
stance those are great tweaks but it is
very much in the same vein of the first
two I found it I mean
locations like the dilapidated areas
even the bosses they kind of just have a
similar feel to them and I don't I
wouldn't say that this is a huge
negative I think for a beloved fan you
might find it this is what I wanted I
want more of what I love and that seems
to be what you're going to get how about
difficulty because these games have
obviously prided themselves on being for
the you know being punishing but fair
presumably now we've had so many of
these games that people have kind of
figured out how to play them so does it
is it feel harder than previous games in
that respect or is it feel like the same
or it feels easier Oh easier really I
mean like I think for me going into it
first again because I haven't played
dark souls so like you and me the same
playing blood-borne just kind of getting
used to the pace it is it faster so I'm
definitely going to play this when it
comes out but uh I was getting punished
in the beginning because i was just so
used to you know either having my gun
and being able to stagger your like i
was using the dodge a lot even though
you have a shield you know and you can
block and that's a very dark souls thing
to do right but i was playing it like
blood-borne you know just like i'm gonna
dodge everything and i think like after
like the first time you go through
blood-borne it's kind of a struggle
getting through each part of it but then
you get you learn and get better yeah
and then your second playthrough you
start going ok how do i how do i refine
all those things i did and then like
you're trying to pull out all these
visceral tax all these back stabs and
all that all those things I think that's
going to come with time especially with
this game so I think it's still hard
like how hard you know I didn't play
dark souls 2 so hard to say but I think
there's still like a slight learning
curve because you're still learning like
enemy types attack news right that's
really what these games are about it's
like learning how they're gonna tack you
like what are their attack patterns like
but then I got some probably a lot of
this is probably new for you yep so did
you feel like that Mario did you kind of
did you think you had all the enemies
figured out largely because they're
similar to debris these games he's right
there is a learning curve you know that
boss takes a lot of time to take down I
felt in general though because I am
familiar with a lot of the way you would
see a generic skeleton guy that I knew
how to take him down but again there's a
lot of fine tuning so there's a lot more
to it than what we see
and then this is invading someone else's
world right another live player well
that's a whole nother can of worms like
that guy is hard and I this is this was
a tough one for me how was that lag uh
it's real is our third person there is
in fact I don't know if I look up
there's about four other people up there
watching and cheering us on so we're all
fighting each other this happened just
randomly during the your playthrough
well you decide to do this you use our
red eye orb and those are like an item
that you can use as many times as you
want like a specific area uh well yeah
in this area at least for this demo it
took me here I find the if you're red
then you want to kill the white guy and
if you're white you want to kill the red
guy so it's kind of like a multiplayer
mode as opposed to the sort of you know
killer becomes constant persistent
multiplayer thing that we've known in
the dark souls are like offhanded
leaving notes in one not definite this
is just like you just drink something
and you're in a multiplayer match it
changes it up right um and it's its
aggressive this stuff yeah I did not
Montreal more I did not survive yeah the
messages are still there so like most of
them at least from the test when we
played we're pretty legit there were
some trolls like I read one where it's
like illusionary wall ahead and it's
literally right in front of you and I
was a dumbass and I try to walk for and
I'm like like wait that didn't work and
I try to bring it it didn't work you
know but they're still co-op too so that
that's pretty fun you're supposed to
vote those downer up base I totally
moded that down once I appraised it with
a negative walking I've been in the same
in Assassin's Creed syndicate yeah two
stars oh yeah we're talking about
nothing yeah that's coming up yeah stay
tuned but yeah I think in terms of
another thing that you want to see from
a Dark Souls game from dark souls 1 that
had these really wonderful intricate
levels that when you went into an area
you came out maybe back at the beginning
where you started and they they would
have these wonderful ways of weaving the
world in and out so you always felt like
you were you were in this labyrinth that
never ended it was really beautifully
done i was i was a big fan of that dark
souls 2 not so much he kind of went to
the end and then he turned around he
came back in this demo even though it
was very small this stress test
everything warped back cool
and there were parts where it wouldn't
let me go forward but if I looked off
out in the distance I could see where it
was going and it was coming back around
so it looks like the level is more it's
more intricate and it's more about
weaving it back to where you began which
is really exciting for me because I'm
excited to see how they do that there's
nothing better and getting to the end of
an area and taking an elevator and
finding out that you just saved yourself
20 yeah exactly there was something that
game came back in blood-borne as well
it's a good feeling to know that even if
like how do you know that you've
progressed in a game like that you know
you always feel like you don't progress
but when you get to a bonfire you get or
you use your souls and level up or you
get one of those elevators you unlock a
door like I've done something I
accomplished a lot and I've saved myself
a lot of time so it's good to good to
see that those are making a return
excellence so you guys optimistic than
the best blood-borne going to it's so
quick I'm sorry enough over dr. sweets
it's it's crazy to think like it's
another game to look forward to that's
put us on African or six months oh it's
good though that's good yeah it is you
know you can we got we got time to play
all our winter titles you know you got
the fallouts of tomb raiders of the
world blood-borne expansion on it yeah
you know halo obviously in Assassin's
Creed so we have all that time to play
that stuff and then right around the
corner next year you know we'll have a
Dark Souls game but I'm excited it looks
good again haven't played a Dark Souls
game web blood weren't totally got me
hooked got me into it and after playing
the stress test i'm i'm i'm ready to
play this one so excellent point to it
all right we better let you guys get
back to resting running the show before
it all before the fire consumes us all
Eric take medication thanks so much for
coming on I'm talking to his bed Dark
Soul straight
you